hi there steve here again uh continuing
in this series
uh about the application of steve
covey's uh
very inspiring book seven habits of
highly effective people and how it
applies to language learning and his
fifth habit was what he calls you know
seek first to understand then
to be understood
and
this applies in life we should always
listen before talking hear what people
have to say
if we understand what they have to say
we can respond to it much better well
the same is true in language learning
and that's why
my whole approach to language learning
is so heavily input based
i want to understand i want to
understand the culture i want to
understand uh what people have to say i
want to feel confident that in any um
conversation
there won't be any big surprises i won't
find myself constantly saying i beg your
pardon a bigger pardon so that this
developing this
level of understanding is is key
uh then what we have to say is going to
make sense it's going to be a response
to what people said it's not just going
to be trotting out a few uh sentences
that we'll you know that we feel
confident uh in uttering it and it also
gets back to some of these other um
habits like the win-win in other words
any engagement you have with the
language if you are connecting with it
you're understanding you're listening
you're reading
all of this is a powerful win
so by having a
learning strategy that focuses on
understanding
uh you're guaranteeing yourself the
sense of win and achievement if on the
other hand you look at language learning
as a performance and then you're
constantly second guessing yourself and
oh i didn't speak as well as i would
like i wasn't able to express my
thoughts
i
struggled to find words
whereas when you are listening you're
constantly gaining you're constantly
learning listening and reading
understanding understanding not only the
language but understanding some aspect
of the culture so i i just find that
this emphasis on understanding the
language the culture on soaking it in
rather than
wanting to trot out the few sentences
that you can use
is is a much more long lasting
much more in the long run satisfying
way and it builds up a solid base from
which to develop your output skills so
seek first to understand
then to be understood
i think that applies to language
learning